Oh, oh, whoops, I forgot the most important part.
Give me a sec.
I forgot to do something very important.
Whoops, I knew I forgot something.
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
It's me.
I was like, did I forgot something?
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait, why is it not working?
Okay.
Wait, is it because...
Oh, I'm on.
Oh, okay.
I've been on date an entire time.
Oh, whoops, on my phone.
Whoops, okay.
Alright, sorry.
My brain's not working today.
Okay, so...
Alright.
I have to let you guys know that...
It might have been a big mistake to schedule a...
A stream...
A game...
That's all about talking...
Right after two...
Back to back...
Long hour streams.
And...
Especially one where I was streaming for 17 plus hours.
So...
We're not gonna do a toad voice today.
Because my throat...
Today...
I should be resting my throat.
So...
But...
Here we are.
Um...
There's no toad...
There's no toad voices.
Um...
So it's just gonna be regular voice jokey.
Also...
If you guys didn't know...
Um...
Spicy foods...
Are not good for your throat.
When you're like...
Trying to like...
You know...
Relax your throat.
And then...
Uh...
And you guys wanna know what I ate today?
Or...
Yeah...
Today...
I was like...
You know what?
I'm craving some spicy noodles today.
But it tasted great though.
My stomach's happy.
My throat is not...
Yes, I ate the bulldog noodles today.
Um...
It was not just like bulldog noodles.
It was like...
Those like...
Korean sandwiches.
Like the giant omelette sandwiches on...
Um...
Like the famous Korean street food.
But they added like...
Bulldog noodles on top of it.
And I was like...
Ooh...
Mmm...
That sounds delicious.
And it was.
But my throat is not happy right now.
So...
It might not be a super long stream today.
Um...
But...
We're still here.
So...
I might be more...
Relaxed and comfy.
And like...
I'm not gonna do voices today, unfortunately.
So there's no todoki today.
Um...
Anyway!
Alright!
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah!
So for those who don't know...
Uh...
Yesterday...
I might have streamed...
17 hours of Marvel Rivals.
Um...
I know...
Realized that...
It might have been a bad idea...
To...
You know...
Make the tournament VOD...
11 plus hours on YouTube.
Because I realized...
You know...
This was sort of a big deal with the people I was playing with.
Especially like...
One of them was Tyler1.
And I feel like...
A lot of people are now...
Not gonna watch the VOD...
Because they're gonna see it's...
11 plus hours.
So...
People might...
Miss out...
On the interactions...
With like...
Like...
As the team.
Because...
I mean...
If you see the VOD...
And you see like...
11 plus hours...
People might not want to click that VOD...
To watch it back.
I realized...
Oh wait...
I sort of fucked up a little bit.
My addiction sort of...
My...
Marvel Rivals addiction...
Sort of like...
You know...
Fucked me a little bit over...
About thinking what could be good for my channel.
I...
So...
So I was like...
Oh man...
Maybe I should...
I...
I should have definitely moved the rink grinding...
Over to Twitch...
So that I could kept the VOD short...
Instead of...
You know...
11 plus hours...
I could have...
Made it...
Um...
I could have made it...
A lot shorter...
Um...
Yeah...
So...
Uh...
So I was like...
Oops...
Uh...
Well I guess a lot of people are gonna miss out on the fact that I played with him.
Um...
I...
Whoopsie...
Um...
Uh...
But yeah...
Anyway...
What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah...
Um...
Uh...
My friends told me this today...
And it made me a...
A little bit...
Feel a little bit...
I feel like...
Better...
Okay...
So...
I didn't even realize this...
But...
Um...
During the last match...
Against XQC's team...
Um...
I didn't even...
I was thinking about that...
But like...
Uh...
I'm not gonna make an edited video...
Because it was...
It's not that long...
By the way...
In that tournament...
And I feel like there's...
I don't know...
Um...
I'll think about it...
But like...
Like...
I didn't realize that...
Um...
XQC's team...
Basically...
Like...
I wouldn't say Target banned me...
But like...
They banned...
Loki and Adam...
Which would've been the two healers...
I would've played...
If like...
They didn't do it...
And...
Like...
I just...
I really...
I didn't realize that...
Um...
And obviously we banned Luna...
So like...
I couldn't do anything about that too...
Uh...
And then...
Cause my friends were telling me...
That...
Um...
Because they...
The reason why...
Our team...
Was doing really well...
Was because...
I was technically the second DPS...
For our team...
By playing Loki and...
Adam...
Because I wasn't really thinking about it...
Cause like...
When I was on Adam...
I was like...
Making a lot of impact as Adam...
Being like...
Literally the second DPS...
And doing...
A lot of like...
Um...
Doing a lot of like...
Like kills and damage through it...
And then like...
On Loki...
I have three clones...
And...
I was also like...
Doing...
Like you know...
Keeping everybody alive...
With my lamps...
And like the three clones I had...
And I didn't...
I wasn't thinking about it...
I was like...
Oh wait...
You're right...
Cause then I was like...
I was like...
Yeah...
I have to play on Sue...
Because like...
We're already really limited...
Like...
We're already like...
Super limited...
On the supports we were...
We had...
Since there were three of us...
And like...
Sue is a good pick...
But like...
She doesn't have any...
Fragging potential...
And like...
All I could do was just...
Keep my...
Keep my players alive...
At that point...
Like...
Yeah...
I can shield and everything...
But there was no...
I couldn't help...
With output...
With damage anymore...
I really...
And I was like...
Wait...
And I was thinking back...
I was thinking back...
Like...
Oh yeah...
I got some really...
Clutch kills...
And like...
I helped with the damage department...
For my team...
When I was on Loki...
And Adam...
And because...
Like...
They banned...
The DPS supports...
Like...
I was...
Stuck in...
Just supporting...
I couldn't do damage...
For my team anymore...
And like...
It made me realize...
Like...
It made me feel a lot better...
I...
I definitely felt a lot better...
Knowing that...
Cause I was like...
Oh...
I had impact!
I was like...
On my team!
Yay!
We lost...
But I still...
I...
I did something!
I had...
Value!
Yippee!
But...
Like...
I was like...
Wait...
You're right...
They like...
Sorta target banned me...
And it worked!
I mean...
They also target banned Tyler1...
But...
And I also...
Fucked us over...
And...
But they also...
Got rid of...
The second DPS...
The second hidden DPS!
And like...
And it just made me really happy...
Um...
It just made me...
Really happy...
Um...
Just cause of the fact that...
You know...
I like...
Um...
Did something...
To like...
Be focused...
You know?
I was like...
Yippee!
Um...
Uh...
What else did I want to talk about?
I wrote...
You know...
I always write down stuff...
I want to talk about...
Um...
Oh yeah...
So...
The reason why...
Uh...
Chakori...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Target ban also means...
Can't proper ban...
Yippee!
Wait...
What do you mean by that?
I don't really understand that sentence...
Uh...
Um...
I mean like...
I can put on my support...
Fine...
But we got rid of all the supports...
That...
Can do damage...
Except for Jeff...
But like...
Um...
Can do damage...
And heal at the same time...
I mean we have Jeff...
But then I...
It requires me to be the flanked Jeff...
And...
I'm sorry...
I...
I don't trust...
My team...
To like...
I don't trust my team...
To...
Heal...
Without me...
Um...
Which is a little harsh to say...
But like...
Yeah...
That's...
It's...
It's what it is...
Um...
What was I...
Oh...
Oh wait...
Sorry...
My mind is all over the place...
Because...
Um...
Uh...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba...
...my mind is all over the place...
Because...
Uh...
Oh my god, wait, I actually lost my track of that.
Wait, okay, what was I... What was my last sentence before my cogs, like, jammed?
What was I talking about?
Before it, like, jammed, I'm trying to kickstart it.
No, the last sentence that I was trying to say.
No, no, no, and I was, like, going through a sentence.
Was I actually still talking about Marvel Rivals?
I swear I was trying to move on to another topic.
Oh!
Doki Amber Doge update.
Okay.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Got it.
So 16 hours of Marvel Rivals is good, but 17 hours is too much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, so I was... the reason why, um, I started a little bit late is because...
Oh yeah, before I say that, also remember this thought for me after that.
I was a Doki Amber Doge.
Sorry, I'm, like, jumping all over the place.
When I'm not so brain rotted and my mind is not, like, turning slowly, I can focus on one topic.
I don't have ADHD.
I know people keep thinking I have ADHD, but I don't.
But, like, I want to talk about this other topic before I go into the Doki Amber Doge topic because it's related to the last topic I talk about.
I know that sounds all confusing, but you think about it, it will make sense.
Um, anyway...
Anyway, I want to say, um, I basically...
The day... the day after the 17-hour Marvel Rivals grind, I literally was just in my bed the whole day.
Like, I woke up, and I just laid there watching YouTube shorts.
I did not do anything else.
Now, that's why the waiting room was so lit.
I had to push up an hour because I'm, uh...
Uh, because I was just laying in a bed just, like, disassociated because 17 hours was maybe a little too much.
I think if I didn't have a six-hour Dynasty War of streams the day before, I think it would have been fine.
Yeah, it's, like, post-gaming clarity.
No, it's 100% that.
You know, like, how you start regretting?
You know the word?
Post-not-clarity?
Post-rivals clarity.
I was like, maybe that...
Oh, it was a mistake.
Like, that's wild.
Post-post-rivals clarity.
Um, anyway.
Uh, and, like, and, like, I actually got it all out of my system, and I'm like, yeah, I don't really want to play rivals for a while.
Like, really?
I was like, well, that's...
I think I played enough rivals for the next at least two to three days.
I...
You know, okay.
You know that famous image of, like...
Okay, I know it's, like, a meme from another meme.
But, like, there was one where, like, Mr. Fantastic or, like, Mrs. Fantastic, depending on, like, which one you want to be, is all, like, shriveled up in bed.
And then, like, Mr. or Mrs. Fantastic is, like, eh, day after tomorrow.
That's... I'm the shriveled up person.
And then the other one is, like, Marvel Rivalist.
That...
Like, that meme?
Wait, wait.
Let me find it.
Let me...
It's safe for work, by the way.
Mr. Fantastic...
Ms. Fantastic...
Bed...
Meme...
For those who want to know...
Wait, what is...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Uh...
Wait, is there, like, an actual picture of this?
Okay, give me a sec.
No!
There has to be a picture of this!
An artwork!
Oh, my God.
What is the right Google...
Google prompt for this?
Okay.
Twitter.
Ms. Fantastic.
Meme.
All right.
Wait.
Ms. Fantastic.
Bed.
Oh, my God.
Meme.
Why didn't I save it?
I just...
I just wanna know!
I need to see the...
The picture!
Okay.
Mr. Fantastic...
Shriveled...
Up...
In...
Bed.
Do I have...
Do I have to...
Okay.
I've got the Ms. Fantastic version.
I don't have the Mr. Fantastic version.
I don't know where that one is.
I...
All right.
So, I don't know where the Ms. Fantastic version is.
But...
Oh, Mr. Fantastic.
Okay.
So, this is...
All right.
So, that's...
I'm Ms. Fantastic.
And then that's Marvel Rivals.
That's...
Wait.
I have a better one.
We have a better version.
Marvel R...
Wait.
Let me Photoshop this real quick.
Let me...
Wait.
Guys.
No, this is very important.
I have to Photoshop this.
So, you can understand...
The full context.
Let me...
I'm cookie right now.
Let me Photoshop this real fast.
All right.
Okay.
Let me see.
And then...
All right.
Don't worry.
It'll be so worth it, guys.
It's so stupid.
Okay.
Give me...
Guys.
No.
I swear to God.
It'd be...
It'd be so worth it.
When you...
When I...
When I fix this picture.
I swear to God.
All right.
This is...
This is me.
That's me on the right.
For the whole day.
I was like...
That's the whole...
The whole day.
I was just like...
Oh, man.
I need to make my waiting room.
I...
I need to...
I need to make my waiting room.
I...
Oh, yeah.
God looks even worse.
Wait.
You're right.
Let me make it better.
No.
You're so right.
I knew I'm missing something.
Um...
Wait.
Guys.
You're right.
Sorry.
I forgot one important addition to...
To this beautiful...
Picture.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Um...
Wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
All right.
Watch this.
Watch this update in real time.
I forgot one...
One more thing.
Let me be perfect.
Let me...
All right.
Give me a sec.
We're updating this in real time.
All right.
There you go.
Now...
Okay.
So, like...
That's basically how I felt today.
When I...
I woke up.
I was just like...
I was like...
Oh, my God.
I should not have played 17 hours of my marrivals yesterday.
I'm...
I was not ready for it.
I was...
I thought...
I thought I was...
I thought I was really okay.
But I was...
I was not okay.
I was not...
I was...
I was not okay at all.
Let's move yourself over half the...
I was...
Yeah, so...
That...
That's basically...
How I felt...
When I woke up.
And why the waiting room...
Took so long.
Oh, by the way...
Okay, who's the artist for this?
I...
I just don't even know the...
Okay.
I also credit the artist too.
Because...
This is the artist, by the way.
Thank you for making such a beautiful picture.
Here you go.
By the way, this is...
I edited it though.
I am the artist of the original picture.
But...
Don't forget the goodnight, Dragoon stream in the chair.
In the chair.
Lali for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah.
So...
That's basically me in bed.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Why did I do that?
Why did I...
I felt...
I felt invincible yesterday.
I could have...
I felt like I could have gone on even longer.
I like...
I could have...
I thought...
Yesterday I was like...
I could have streamed...
For two...
At least two to three more hours.
If those...
E-daters didn't...
Fucking ruin it for me.
Who would have thought...
It was a bad idea.
Oh my god.
But that's why I'm like...
More...
Out...
Right...
Um...
A little bit more out of it.
And my mind...
Mind's cogs...
Are turning...
Really, really slow.
Okay.
So those who don't know...
Who missed out on...
Yesterday's...
Twitch adventures...
Um...
Right after I finished streaming on YouTube...
I went straight to Twitch...
Um...
To like finish the job...
Because I was like...
That's it.
I'm not done yet.
Let's continue this on Twitch.
You think the 12 hour...
VOD limit is gonna stop me?
I'm gonna...
I'm...
I'm ready for round two...
Of Marvel Rivals.
And...
The only reason...
I ended the stream...
Was because...
The last game I had...
I bumped into an...
To an e-couple...
To the e-date...
Um...
I bumped into a...
E-couple slash e-daters...
Um...
On my team...
And all they were doing...
Was just yelling at each other...
And like bringing up...
Their like...
Fight...
To end a public rank match...
It was...
It was fucking wild.
It was so cringe.
I...
Like they were yelling...
It was so...
It was like a toxic fight too.
Cause they're like...
She was like...
I don't even know why I'm playing with you right now.
You were spamming me.
I couldn't even brush my teeth in the morning.
And you were spamming me to play with you.
Oh my god.
I don't even know why I have to play with...
I'm playing with you.
And I was like...
What the fuck?
I was like... I was just like, what the fuck is going on here?
And they were just yelling at each other for the entire time of the second half.
And she, yeah, she even said, no one likes you.
And I was like, whoa.
And then the guy was like, I'm not boasting you anymore after this game.
And I was like, what?
Like, he was like, I don't even want to play with you.
You know what?
I'll do it with someone else.
Yes, in open comms.
They were fun.
I was like, do you not have a Discord together?
Like, why are you not talking about it in your disc?
Why are you bringing us along with it?
Do you, like, get off on, like, a public audience?
What?
Like...
I was thinking...
Like, do you not... Is this, like, a thing for you?
Is this a kink?
Like, is this a kink?
Like, are you... Do you just want to, like, bring this to the public, like, audience?
And then, like, and then, like, it makes you so heated?
And you're like, oh, this is so hot.
Arguing in a public space.
Like, it makes it feel more real for them.
It's part of the play.
Oh, my God.
Public...
The more people watching, the better it is for them by bringing it in.
It makes the relationship feel more real.
I was a very unwilling participant.
And that is why...
That was why we stopped there.
Because I was like...
I was like, guys, I don't think I'm into...
I don't...
Guys, I don't think I want to play anymore.
Because if these are the queues I'm gonna...
If I've queued so late that I've bumped into an e-couple arguing...
Right?
Arguing in my game.
And then, like, making me feel a little bit uncomfortable.
Because I feel like this might be part of their play.
Hey, I think it's time to get off the internet.
I feel like I need...
I think it's time to stop.
Yeah, and they were also throwing.
They were throwing, but somehow...
The enemy team started throwing too.
It was crazy.
And I was like...
Also, I realized people were starting to throw.
And I was like, yeah, I don't think it's a clam day.
I don't think we're gonna be clamming anymore.
I don't...
But yeah, that's what happened.
That's basically what happened.
Anyway, dad update.
Dad update.
So, dad's gonna come home tomorrow night.
Um, because, um, the dog sitter can't take care of him, uh, this week.
So, he's gonna be coming home tomorrow night.
Um, that means, um, I'm not sure how the schedule's gonna be going for tomorrow...
Like, starting next week.
Um, cause I don't know how...
How much I have to supervise him.
They did say he was recovering a lot.
And I'm just...
And I did order more ramps for him.
Just in case...
I don't want him to...
You know, of course, I don't want him to jump.
Because, like, he just got back from a very expensive surgery.
Um, so, um...
Um, he's gonna be coming home tomorrow night.
Um, this may or may not affect the schedules and stuff.
Um, we'll see how it goes.
Um, that might also mean I might not...
I don't know if I'll be...
It depends if he's sleeping.
If I put him in a locked kennel...
Um, not kennel, sorry.
If I put him in his own...
Maybe I'll try and get a box.
Just, like, how they did.
And then just put him in the box when I...
And put him next to me in the box.
When I do, like, longer streams.
But I'll figure that out tomorrow.
Cause I don't know, like, what...
This scenario's gonna be like.
Um, when he's actually home.
Um, but I do need to supervise him and everything.
So he'll most likely be, like, next to me and stuff.
In his own little doggy box.
Or whatever I use to keep him confined in an area.
And everything.
So, we'll see how...
But, like, the only thing I'm worried about...
Like I said...
My office is, like, a little sauna.
So, like, that's the thing I'm most worried about.
Because my office is, like, a little sauna.
And I don't know if he's, like, gonna be comfortable in my office.
Um, because right now...
I'm having a little bit of trouble breathing.
Because I need to turn up the aircon a little bit.
Give me a sec, actually.
I'm having a little trouble breathing right now.
Because it's so hot in my office.
I'll be right back, guys.
Speaking of that.
Okay, I turn up the...
I turn up the little...
I turn up the aircon right now.
So, it should get a little better when it's a little cooler.
So, I'll see how it goes.
Um...
Because I don't know how much he wants to move.
Because the dogster was telling me that he likes to move a lot.
Like, he's starting to...
Wanting to...
Uh...
Move a lot now.
And I'm, like, a little worried that he might try moving a lot when I'm not watching him.
So, we'll see.
I just need to talk to...
That's what I was, like, talking to the dog sitter about.
So, that's a little dad update.
Um...
They did say...
They could take care...
They're gonna see if they could take care of him later on.
Um...
Because, like I said, I feel like...
Them taking care of dad during his, you know, recovery period is a better decision than me taking care of him.
Because I'm only one person.
Um...
But...
The dog sitter is, like, an entire family with children, with teenagers.
Um...
Who have been looking after them for the last two weeks.
And, um...
You know, yeah, there's a lot of people looking after him and stuff.
So, they were able to monitor him much better than me.
And, like, giving him the best care possible.
So, if it's possible...
Like, I'm gonna see if it's possible to have him go back to the dog sitter later on.
Um...
To continue the, like, you know, continue the treatment and stuff like that.
And the physical therapy exercises.
Because I just feel like, uh...
They were doing really well with the care in general.
And I'm worried about taking care of him by myself.
Because, you know, I feel like I lack the experience a lot.
So, we'll see.
We'll see.
But that's the dad update.
Um...
Hmm...
I don't think there's anything else.
Anyway, let's actually...
Let's actually play the game.
Um...
It won't be a long stream today.
Unfortunately.
But, uh...
Maybe, like...
One to two hours.
Um...
Uh...
P-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p.
So...
Oh, not one to two hours.
Uh, two hours maximum today.
Just because I do have another stream tonight with Goodnight Dragoons.
And, um...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, for those who didn't know, I rescheduled Goodnight Dragoons today!
Because, you know, I was...
I...
I had a no problem.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha.
Uh...
And, uh...
And, yeah.
I don't want to, like, do too much to my voice today.
Oh, guys.
Let's get started.
With Mario-man.
Okay.
Wait, I forgot to turn on the sound.
But, yeah.
I'm looking forward to seeing Dad again.
It's been, like, a long time.
I think it's been, like, almost a month since we last saw him.
So, I do miss him a lot.
Oh, yeah.
I'm in this, like, really fucked up city, too.
Guys, thank you for the Magenta Super.
Thank you.
It's been ten days since I was taking off the couch to play.
Only come back to find out my couch occupied by a non-shiny bullet bill.
And me stuck in the corner.
At first, I was, um, indigent.
But lately, I've started to enjoy this new place.
It's just...
Thank you for the Magenta Super.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Uh, bu-bu-bu-bu-bu.
Alright, let's go.
Just enjoy your time.
I don't remember where I've, like, interacted and talked to.
Is it here?
Oh, wait.
That's the...
Wait, where is this area?
Wait, no, I don't...
No!
I accidentally...
Did it...
What a...
I didn't...
Oh!
I accidentally spent my money.
I don't...
Oh, my God.
God damn it.
It's okay.
I've made...
I gotta learn from my mistakes.
The music is too loud to get their attention.
Guys, if I save Scum, then I'll never learn.
You can't get Jimmy T's attention.
He is grooving too hard.
You ain't ever gonna owe it for all of this move and show him you know how to boogie at.
You up for it, darling?
Woo!
Let's just go with the flow and you'll do great.
Let's get groovy.
Boom.
Groovy!
See?
Even when brain rotted, I remember.
Let's get groovy.
Down.
Right, right.
Left.
Oh.
Yeah!
Dance, dance, dance!
Dance!
Let's get groovy!
Down.
Left.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Okay, wait.
I got this.
That's right.
Oh.
You're a superstar, alright?
Smooth moves, man.
Jimmy T is waiting for you in the room ahead.
Alright, yay!
Hello, Jimmy T.
Fight me!
Mario.
When was the last time you've been to Club Sugar?
Honey?
I remember you came for those breakdancing courses.
I hope you still remember how.
That's because Club Sugar hasn't changed a bit.
Silly 24-7 party!
What do you need, honey?
You need a passcode for Wario Studio?
Show me love on the dance floor, then!
Let's get groovy, baby!
That reminds me.
I really want to watch Austin Powers again.
Those movies age so well.
They're still as fun.
Like, I saw, like, a clip of it recently.
I don't know.
It just showed up in my YouTube.
Yeah, it holds up really well.
I saw it, like, a clip of it pop up in my YouTube algorithm.
And, um...
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Okay, maybe some jokes are, like, a little bit more inappropriate now.
Or, like, a lot really, really inappropriate.
But, like, some of the jokes are still really, really funny.
I just remembered.
Um...
Sorry, from the clips I watched...
From the clips I watched...
Uh...
It may be a little dated.
It may be a little dated in some moments.
But some of the clips I watched were not those moments, but were the funny clips that aged well.
Because I was thinking back, I was like, no, I think there were some very inappropriate jokes.
But I saw two clips that popped up in my algorithm.
And I saw two clips that popped up in my algorithm.
And it was the part where it was a flashback to back when Austin Powers and Dr. Evil were in high school or some shit.
And another one where it was Mini-Me and Austin Powers trying to find a map or some shit.
And I was like, oh yeah, that's pretty funny.
I need to watch those movies again.
And like, I forgot that... I forgot that like, Dr. Evil and Austin Powers were both played by...
What's his name?
Was it Seth Meyers?
That's the actor, right?
Or the Shrek guy.
We're both played by Shrek.
And like, oh, Mike Meyers.
Sorry, Seth Meyers.
Sorry.
Mike Meyers.
I got confused.
I was like, it was something Meyers.
And I chose Seth because Seth likes Shrek.
I was just thinking like...
Oh yeah, Seth Green!
I think I was thinking...
Yeah, I was thinking of Seth Green and Mike Meyers at the same time.
Because I know Seth Green was in the movie as well.
But yeah, Dr. Evil and Austin Powers were both the same actor.
And I forgot about that.
I don't know, sir.
But it looks like a giant.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe the members' good movie watch a lot.
I may watch Austin Powers.
Because it's been a long time since I watched Austin Powers.
By the way, the very first time I watched Austin Powers...
My... Wait, actually, let me look it up.
My parents loved Austin Powers, by the way.
My dad fucking loved that movie.
Or the movie series.
Like, he would do like, random quotes about like...
He would do like, random Austin Powers quotes to me.
When I was growing up.
He'd be like, yeah, baby...
Like, groovy, baby.
Like, to me.
And he's like...
And then you know like, the Dr. Evil pose?
Stuff?
He would like, do that pose to me.
And like...
I just remember like...
Like, if he wants to like, pretend to be Dr. Evil...
Like, do something evil.
Do the Dr. Evil pose to me.
And stuff like that.
Uh...
Because he was like, obsessed with the movie.
Yeah, the pinky pose.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't know when these movies...
I didn't know when these movies released.
Oh, yeah.
So...
Um...
My parents loved the Austin Powers movie series so much.
They had all the DVDs back then.
And then like, when the last Austin Powers movie that came out...
They...
Took...
Little me...
To the movie theaters...
To watch...
The film.
I have...
No idea...
How...
Legally...
I was allowed to watch it.
I...
I was...
Very little...
When the last movie came out.
And...
I have like...
Incredibly vague memories...
Of like...
Austin Powers in Goldmember.
I have...
Very vague memories of in the theater...
Watching that movie with them.
I don't...
Like...
But I have no idea...
How...
I was allowed in...
To like...
Be there.
Because...
I remember...
Rewatching that...
Um...
In like...
Middle school or something.
And I was like...
Wait a minute...
This movie is incredibly inappropriate.
That explains a lot.
Isn't this movie like...
PG-13?
As in...
Like...
Wait...
Rating...
I don't think a child should be allowed in...
I don't...
Um...
Okay...
Oh it is!
It's PG-13.
Does that mean like...
Am I even...
Are they allowed to...
Oh wait...
Unless there's a parent there.
Yeah...
It should be a...
Fine, right?
Like...
Is it...
Um...
Mickey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just strongly cautioned.
Um...
Hey, Joe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think the only thing that aged poorly about...
Austin Powers...
Was random task actor being convicted of bad things.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gus, you need to get a toggle for the pinky pose during the watch along.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's keep...
Sorry that...
I don't know why...
But like...
When he started being like...
It's groovy time.
It just reminded me of Austin Powers.
Alright.
Oh, okey okey!
O kiki, o kiki!
You kiki?
Was it o kiki or you kiki?
Furious, thank you super chat, thank you thank you.
It's a get in my belly!
Seeing actually not to...
to bore everything is bore.
You think about it?
Monkey!
Alright, get it.
Time for monkey to die.
The world has too much, too many monkeys now.
Yeah, it's... wait, is that... no, no, no, it's... wait, his... his mouth looks like balls.
Sorry.
We can never escape monkey.
No.
Dad will do it all.
Thanks, Doki.
Wait, how... oh wait, it's not doing a lot of damage.
Uh, Masamun, Masamun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, uh, it's my birthday today.
And I'm still up at 3.52am.
Getting a year older.
Doki Walsker arrives tomorrow.
Thanks for your streams.
Or in German.
Don't get for done streams.
Greetings from Germany.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so happy you like my streams.
And happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Masu.
Happy birthday.
Thank you.
Oh, we have a great birthday today.
You go, Dad.
Take all the XP.
You know, like that meme where like, that family guy meme.
I'm sorry.
I want to do it.
One day, I want to do a stream where I just do like, family guy cuts.
It's like, remember the time when I...
You guys remember the time when I, uh, played with Tyler1 and I just cut to like... Or like, I just make up random memories we've had.
I'll be like, remember that time I like, saved an entire family from a burning building?
Um, while in the middle of the stream?
And then like, everyone was freaking out and then I just cut to that, like, cut to a reimagined scene of like, what...
Of that happening?
I just make a re... Like, I just like...
Do like a fake scene cut of it.
Like, where a fake stream moment with an editor.
Where it seems like this might have happened.
And you're like, did I forgot that?
Like, was... It's like those... It's like the Rick and Morty opening where they insert fake episodes in the opening.
And people will be like, wait, which one's from a real episode and which one isn't?
And then I'll just like...
And then I'll create like, fake...
Like, make fake stream moments with an editor.
And then it'll just make you second guess.
I was like, wait, did this actually happen?
It'll be from streams I've actually done.
But like, from games I've actually done.
But I just like, created a whole new moment in it.
And you have to look back into the VOD and be like, did this actually happen?
Or I'm like, fucking schizo right now.
Am I like...
Is this a bear-stained bear moment?
Am I getting Mandela affected?
I'm...
Doki is cooking.
Smooth moves, Mario.
I would love to give you the whole passcode.
Oh yeah, by the way, I was gonna say, it reminded me of that Family Guy episode where they cut to this actor eating like all the food and their family is starving.
He's like, please father, can I also have a meal?
Can I also have a bite?
And he's like, no!
It's all mine.
That's dad with my other Mario mons.
My other Mario mons is like, please Doki.
Please Doki out.
Let me fight.
I want some XP too.
And I'm like, no!
Only dad gets to eat.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
You can have what's left.
Ha ha ha ha.
Yeah, Juno and Kiriko hoarding all the new skins.
Oh yeah, I heard about the controversy with Juno being Chun-Li.
People were like, what the fuck?
Juno getting another skin from our collab?
Ha ha ha ha.
I'd love to give you the whole passcode by only no one word.
The first word is Wario.
But there's nothing left.
There's always nothing left.
Ha ha ha ha.
I hope that helps.
And come by Club Sugar.
Whenever you feel like dancing.
Honey.
Mario found the first word to unlock WarioWare.
Wario!
Yay!
Dance, dance.
I love how...
I like how the longer you yap, the more I know what your YouTube short speed is like.
No, my YouTube short speed is unrelated to anything I talk about.
It's actually...
Okay, my...
My YouTube shorts algorithm is so fucking fucked right now.
And it's opposite to everything I talk about.
It's the...
Okay, I was gonna talk about this today.
Because I was just in my bed watching YouTube shorts all day.
And like...
This is what I get.
I get...
The guy from Japan eats talking about what food he eats every day.
Like, each day he posts about the food he's getting.
And then I get...
Lego shorts.
Where they talk like...
Lego master builders.
And like people talking about like...
Like cool Lego figures.
And then I also get...
I also get like...
Random dance videos.
Of the newest like dance trend.
So like...
Right now I've been getting non-stop shorts.
Of the...
It's that one.
I don't remember that song.
I don't remember the lyrics.
Like...
If you guys know what I'm talking about.
It's...
It's that fucking song.
I...
It's like...
Something blue jeans.
Um...
Oh my god.
What now?
Now I need to figure it out.
Um...
Blue jeans.
A song.
What was it?
Oh my god.
From...
Guy that likes to flip.
All right.
What was it?
Senior that likes to do flips.
During Grammys.
You know.
You know that.
Okay.
Benson Boone.
There he is.
Okay.
Sorry.
It had...
It had to be really specific.
Because all this guy does.
Whenever he has to perform...
Like how someone's like...
Whenever this guy...
Performs.
He does like...
Somersaults and flips.
Every time.
So I had to like...
I had to get really specific.
It's very memorable.
Uh...
Newest song.
All right.
So...
My...
One of my YouTube algorithm...
Is...
Um...
Mystical.
Oh yeah.
Magical.
Ba-ba-ba.
Like that's in my...
That's been in my YouTube feed.
Like that fucking song.
With various different skits.
And like...
Interpretations.
And trend.
Has been on my YouTube feed.
For like...
The past week now.
Like...
It's always that song.
I...
But it's always like...
Okay.
Where is it?
Where...
I need to know.
Huh.
Moon beam.
Ice cream.
Taking off your blue jeans.
Dancing at the movies.
Cause it feels so...
Mystical.
Magical.
Oh baby.
Like...
It...
It's just that part.
And it can't...
I...
There's so many clips.
And now...
Now today...
It's like...
It's like there's a new song now.
That keeps playing.
Uh...
Now people are using this other short.
So I mean...
I need to...
I know what...
I need to know what this is.
I need to know.
Oh.
It was like...
What is it?
Okay.
Wait.
There's this new song today.
It's this one.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh.
You can ask the flowers.
I sit for hours.
Telling all the bluebirds.
The building cool birds.
That's today.
I literally went through 10 shorts in a row using that song on my YouTube shorts algorithm.
I...
It's been...
I was scrolling.
And I was just like...
It was 10 shorts in a row.
It was like...
You can ask the flowers.
I sit for hours.
Telling all the bluebirds.
The building cool birds.
Like, it was literally that.
Like, every time.
Like...
I was like, please.
I love these song trends.
Because they're like really catchy.
But I don't need it 10 times in a fucking row.
I already healed him.
I forgot.
I already healed you.
Sorry.
I had...
When I'm like more brain caught...
My brain is jammed.
I...
I get very easily distracted now.
Also, I need to show you the monkey again.
What is it?
Oh, it's...
Uh...
Ukiki.
Where are you, Ukiki?
Because I told you.
His mouth looks like balls.
And you guys are like...
What the fuck, Doki?
And I'm like...
It's true.
Look at it.
Does it not look like a ball?
Two balls?
Like...
Dominic.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was driving at work this week.
My brain says...
Doki bird.
Dinkle bird.
You're a dinkle bird now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I guess it looks like a butt.
I guess.
But I think it just looks like two balls.
A palm.
I can't see it now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki face.
Can you show us your shock face me while wearing a mustache?
I'm gonna die if I see it.
Alright, sure.
I don't do anything for money.
That's right.
I'm shameless.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love myself out of Oshiii.
Okay, I need to know where the fucking last place is that I'm supposed to go.
Is it here?
That's the department store.
I'm so lost.
Is it...
Here?
Oh, no.
That's the...
Wait, did you guys make another baby?
How?
Oh, my...
I left for like...
Oh, my God.
Okay, you guys...
Yeah, no.
You're gonna make...
Oh, my God.
You guys made another baby?
No, I already did Ashley's Mansion.
I already did that one.
Oh.
Oh, the park is really popular after hours.
You know anyone else playing...
Oh, Pyromon?
I need to trade my Pyroro for a Pyroro.
Have you tried that new Pyromon game?
If you do, tell me how it is.
I can't let go of Super Mario Bros.
3 yet.
Well, I love to make micro games, but I'm a bigger fan of macro games.
Like Super Mario Bros.
3.
Oh, I found a Bros Bean.
Legally distinct.
Uh...
Wario Mon.
This is my zone!
Okay.
What does Yoshi want to say?
Some nice thing you forget about your worries and roll around in a puddle.
I like to give people rides around the playground.
You're a little too big for me.
Are you trying...
What are you trying to say?
Huh?
The other Yoshis could carry my weight.
You're just weak.
I tried eating raw garlic from above?
Yeah, I do not recommend.
Yeah, I'll just share up.
I don't know what that is, but I'll put it in my pocket.
That reminded me of, like, that game we had where that guy was like...
He was like, you know, he's like, don't worry.
I can say it.
I used to be fat, too.
He's like, I got the pass.
I thought I was paying more for a nicer house here in the suburbs.
In reality, they're all the same inside.
My purple coins from World Fort are useless outside the casino.
You know, oh boy, this is the worst of the time I visited Daisy's castle.
And then we're just like, whoa, what do you mean by that?
Because he was like, I was also this, too.
But now I'm just this and not fat anymore.
So I just hate...
I was like, what the fuck?
I'm a try.
Oh, yeah.
I was just like, Jesus.
Bro, I wish I had a cart to ride.
And he's like, it's okay.
I used to be fat once.
So I could say it.
And I was like, Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Rink is crazy.
It makes it so easy to get around Diamond City.
All right.
I'm trying to find the area I was supposed to go to.
Let's say you still don't have all three.
The third...
Where is the third town?
Where is that...
The third town?
See, this is what you missed from the 12-hour vibe.
Mario, be careful.
This world is not what it seems.
Question everything.
What the fuck?
Is that a fourth wall break?
Oh, my God.
He's trying to tell me that I'm in a video game.
Where is the last area?
I did...
Oh, wait.
I didn't do...
I'm stupid.
I didn't do Ashley's mansion.
I'm so dumb.
I forgot.
I did...
I did the...
Sorry.
I did the other girl's thing.
The lab instead of the mansion.
Took you long enough.
Come on.
Sorry.
I got you confused with the other girl.
Oh, it seems to forget...
He forgot to...
Cap jump.
Red, can you keep an eye on Mario?
Of course, Miss Ashley.
Oh?
It seems to be on the switch on the back of the statue.
Press it?
Okay.
Not too difficult.
Trying to depart so quickly, huh?
Oh, there's new encounters here?
Okay, nice.
Oh, this is where I can catch the ghost Pokemon.
Because it's Ashley's mansion.
Bring that back.
Oh my god, you thief.
I knew you can't trust ghosts.
You're all the same.
All right.
I forgot.
I accidentally used a fighting move.
Let's do it.
Ah!
You level up too.
Husky gone.
All right.
Oh, Eerie.
What's that?
Oh!
That's so cute!
Wait, I recognize this is on.
Wait, I want him!
I'm gonna steal it!
I wish I could use like a shadow ball.
Oh my god, he hurt himself.
Curse is such a badass move.
Oh, you're stupid.
This is like me trying to use self-destruct.
The rest of your team is getting the XP.
Yeah!
Bro, like...
I just want...
Okay.
I need a...
I want to catch a ghost Pokemon.
No.
I don't want to be in there.
Put me back in here.
Fight me.
What?
Where is it?
I'm not encountering anything.
Are all the ghosts afraid of me?
How does...
He has like five mons?
That's illegal.
You're just an NPC.
Who gave you the...
NPCs are only allowed to have three or less.
Oh, they're...
They were pretty weak though.
It's like that bug trainer that has six mons.
And they were all like level two.
I wonder like...
What happens?
If you like...
I wish like Pokemon...
Wait, no.
That's Team Rocket.
I wonder...
I was like...
What if I just...
You know...
Just steal your Pokemon.
And I was like...
That's what Team Rocket does.
That's...
That's the whole...
That's what Team Rocket...
The whole thing about Team Rocket.
Where all they do is just steal Pokemon.
That's... death.
Oh my god, I was wondering, like...
You know how, like, I was like, how do you, like, cat, like, you know...
How do you, like, um... report that?
Is it, like, a missing persons report?
I feel like, maybe, like, Pokeballs are, like, hardwired to the Pokemon.
So you cannot transfer a Pokemon to a different ball.
And it's, like, you know, like, find my iPhone?
It's, like, find my Pokemon.
So, like, if you lost your Pokemon somewhere...
Like, what if you, like, left your Pokemon... Pokeball on a bench or something.
And then you just forgot to pick it up.
And, like, you know, how are you gonna get it back?
Then, like, like, you just, you know, it just dropped out of your pants.
And everything.
So, like, how do you get back your Pokemon?
Pokemon!
It's gonna be in that Pokemon!
And I was like thinking, oh my god, what if they have this thing like, find my Pokemon, and it's like a little phone app and everything.
And then you just like go like, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Hahaha!
You're almost there!
And I'm like thinking, like, wouldn't they be like, microchipped too?
You know how like dogs are microchipped?
So wouldn't you like, microchip your mom?
To like, find it?
Alright.
Yeah, to prevent robbery, exactly!
Microchip this guy!
No, it's like implanted on the Pokeball!
And then I guess you can like, microchip like, directly in it.
Yeah, get that Pokemon chipped.
So you don't lose it.
Okay, but like, who made the rules that- Oh, I forgot, that's the same.
Wait, that's a ghost?
Wait, there's a ghost version of me?
Oh no, it's a duplicate!
Okay, I was gonna be like, wait, I'm fighting myself?
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
John and Manny, we saw what she made you do.
And we want to tell you it's not okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Most people... Most Pokemon have, like, human intelligence, far as I remember.
But just don't have a language knowledge.
So they wouldn't want to find you just as much if you were a good mommy for them.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Wait, if they have, like, human intelligence, and we, like, keep them in Pokeballs, and, like, make them do... Like, oh, my first encounter.
I should not have continued that thought, anyway.
That's a good place to stop.
The game was, like, stop!
It finally let me encounter another... a wild mod.
And the game was, like, stop that thought right now!
Look at this wild mod we gave you!
Yay!
I want it, Eerie!
No!
Don't!
Don't kill yourself!
No!
Okay.
That's good.
You can't die twice!
Isn't it, like... Okay, there you go.
I'm trying to capture you!
So you spend your whole life on a PC!
Don't worry, it'll feel just... Oh, no!
No!
Oh, no, it's okay.
Please!
I'm sad.
Alright.
You guys are lucky I'm not doing a Nuzlocke.
I don't understand!
Why won't you want to be caught?
Life is so good in your Pokeball!
What?
Depressed ghost.
Alright, let us...
Alright, we got... At least we got gas mouse.
Ghost mouse.
Fudge!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Reminder that Pokemon the world's only source of...
Oh, yeah!
They are!
Wait, so do you catch them?
To, like, use them as poultry?
Or, like, are they just wild moths that you just go chop chop?
I saw that on, like, one of the official comics where they chopped up a Zubat.
So there's, like, you know, like, we have cat...
Oh, yeah, like, the milk tank farms.
And when the milk tank gets too old...
Chop chop!
Chop!
I'm wondering...
Wait!
Can male milk tanks also make milk?
I'm wondering...
Oh, today's stream is fucking wild.
Lots of dragoons are missing out today.
Wait, there's no male...
Oh, there isn't?
I didn't realize they're gender...
Oh, I didn't realize.
Milk tanks are only coming female form.
The wandering spirit of a mouse, its physical form is weak and can be dispersed effortlessly.
It inhabits old hallways and rooms in spooky mansions.
You know what this mouse reminds me of?
The fact that they said that its physical form is weak and can be dispersed effortlessly?
Now you're in the X sound box.
No!
Oh.
That's cool!
Alright...
Let's see...
Where's the Pokemon Center?
Oh my god, that's... sorry.
I thought... I saw red?
My brain was like, red, Pokemon Center.
And that's like the only thing I registered during that.
I literally just saw red.
Where the fuck is the Pokemon Center?
It's up here, right?
Oh yeah, it's right here.
I was watching by color.
Sorry, Mario Mon Center.
Alright.
This is what it's like when I have no filter today.
I just say all my intrusive thoughts.
Hope I don't get in trouble.
Alright, we gotta go back down here.
Ah, Eerie!
Eerie!
Nice!
Oh, wait, I...
Wait, actually...
Where's my...
I need to get rid of one of you.
Eerie's cute.
Alright.
Lick.
That's right.
Oh, it's super effective!
Wait, what?
Okay, nice.
Okay, this time...
This time you'll get in my ball, right?
You'll get in my cap.
Get in there.
Wait, no.
Wait, why don't you wanna be...
What?
Why don't you wanna be part of my team?
I'll put you in my party.
Don't worry.
You don't have to see what's going on in the exile chamber.
No.
When it...
The people that come out of the exile chamber were never the same after.
A ghostly dinosaur that roams around aimlessly is rather docile and often inflicts damage when others interacted with it by... Oh wait, that's so strong.
Right, Snap.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are we still doing chat names?
Also delivered for you in stream time.
What is it?
I want to see.
What's the delivery?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is it?
Wait.
There's nothing there.
Am I missing it?
Where is it?
Wait, am I looking at the wrong tag?
Oh, no.
Am I looking at the wrong tag, guys?
Oh, wait.
Is it that one?
Oh.
I see it.
I see it, guys.
I got you, Toki.
Retweet it.
Yeah.
I'm going to use that the next time I play Marvel Rivals.
That's going to be my thumbnail.
That's it.
For those who are wondering what it was.
Here you go.
I was looking at...
...Doki Gallery.
Don't worry.
I got you.
That's definitely going to be my next...
...Marvel Rivals thumbnail.
I'll make sure of it.
Also, is the music...
Is the sound okay?
Because I'm not talking as loud as my usual...
...as usual.
Just because, you know, my voice is...
...a bit needs a little rest.
All right.
Yeah.
Don't worry, Rice.
Put you in...
I'll put you as eerie.
Rice.
Goon.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
So cute.
I like that.
I like that Mario mod.
Is there any more encounters in this area?
Or is that it?
I wonder.
What did I do for this one?
Is the sound...
Poo!
This is what I wanted in the first place.
Oh my god.
I wanted a poo.
Finally.
Hey, bat.
Now lick him.
That's right.
Lick him.
Dragoon is like, I'm tired of licking things!
Alright, get in my plumber cap.
No!
Bull was caught!
That gains 78 EXP points.
Yeah!
A long tongue of spirit inhabits a long abandoned home and corner stores.
It vanishes when looked at.
Seeing what is considered something to brag about.
Wait, did I use wisp goons yet?
Did I do wisp goons?
I don't even remember.
I caught so many.
I'm losing track.
Alright, this is gonna be a wisp goon.
Because I think it's perfect for it.
Wisp...
Goon.
Alright!
Bye, wisp goon.
I'm never gonna see you again.
Goodbye.
Into the exile chamber you go.
Where you'll see the horrors.
Mario!
Got it quickly!
No matter what.
In order to proceed, you'll have to face a gauntlet of challenge.
Jizz, are you prepared?
Perfect.
Follow the movements of this toad.
Which toad was?
The blue one, middle.
Yeah!
Oh, well, you won't get the next one so easily.
Follow the movement of this toad.
Middle.
Yeah!
Oh, well, you won't get the next one so easily.
I swear, if this is all just middle.
Okay, this one's left.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
That's so easy.
Correct!
Oh, well, you won't get the next one so easily.
Wait.
Alright, make sure you pay attention to what you're about to see.
What am I about to see?
Oh, this is like the minigames in...
Oh, I was not paying attention.
I looked at chat.
What's a sniff it?
Is it the one guy?
The...
Wait.
What?
Oh, it's the guy with the longer nose, right?
Three, two, four, six, seven.
Okay, three to seven.
Three, seven.
Oh, it's three.
Do it again!
I assume it was the guy with the longer nose just because he had like...
Two, four, six, uh, seven.
Okay, three, seven.
Because like, you know, it had a longer mask.
Oh, seven.
Yeah!
I know what shy guys are.
Next one, you won't win so easily on the next one.
That's it.
Time for the ultimate test.
Luigi!
Huh?
Where did he go?
Hey, where's Luigi?
Wait, what?
What?
I don't understand this one.
Oh!
Yes.
Wait, what?
I...
Was that not the shiny sparkle?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh my god.
It was...
I thought it was like the...
There's so many of them that the sparkle is like hard to see because there's so many things going on.
What?
How?
I gotta tell Miss Ashley about this right away.
She's gonna be so upset.
The sparkle looked like it was on the chair.
That's why I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, it looked like it was...
I thought that it was on the chair because it looked like it was on it.
Miss Ashley!
Mario made it!
Huh?
Of course he did.
I know how this goes.
Are you sure you want to fight?
I can give you the passcode and we can move on.
No.
Wait, I actually want to see what your mons are like.
Okay, you're lost.
I want to see your mons.
I want to know.
I also need the XP too.
I forgot.
Wait, that's so cute.
I want to be a...
I want to be a ghost mon trainer.
Wait, that's so cute.
Oh my god, he's so chubby.
I want to pop it.
I feel like the ghost ones have all the cute designs.
Yeah.
I'll pop those puff cheeks.
Yay, number 20.
Psybeam?
Oh wait, Psybeam is good.
Uh, I'll get rid of Supersonic.
I'm never going to use that anyway.
Like, all the ghost ones in Mario Mon have, like, such cute designs.
All right, nice.
Bruiser?
What does that one look like?
Oh!
It's the Ashley song!
I just noticed!
Remember the song I sent you guys with the jazz version of it?
Yeah, it's the theme.
It's the theme.
I just noticed.
I like that song.
All right.
You can't flinch me forever.
I don't know.
I really like her theme song.
I've...
I've actually never played WarioWare before.
Confession time.
Mad Piano?
Oh, that's from Mario 64!
I recognize it.
Oh!
You know, okay, there's one game that I've been meaning to...
It's not Mario related or Nintendo related.
But...
I really want to play the really fucked up Sonic trilogy game.
Where it was like...
It was like the most random shit they decided to put Sonic in.
Where there was the one where he like becomes a knight.
And then there's another one where he becomes a...
Where he's like a werewolf.
Or...
Yeah.
Yeah, the Sonic...
Black...
Yeah, I actually was like...
Oh my god.
I still really want to...
Play the storybook...
Yeah, the storybook trilogy.
Yeah, I was like...
Thinking about it recently.
I was like...
Man, when do I want to play it?
This...
I've never played those games before.
But I've heard like...
It's like...
Fucking weird.
It's where like...
Sonic got a little weird.
A little edgy.
Yeah, I want to play the trilogy and the werehog.
The third word is...
Win!
Now, be gone!
Mario found the third word to unlock WarioWare.
Win!
Alright, time to go back to the Pokmon Center.
Let's go back to the Pokmon!
Wow!
Yes!
I'm gonna win!
Wow!
When will I meet Waluigi?
I just want to... I want to meet my hero, Waluigi.
My Oshii.
I just want to say I have really good taste in Oshii's.
Okay, I don't remember where he lives.
Waluigi Doko!
Okay, that's Ashley's place.
Where the fuck is the...
warehouse?
Okay, that's the center.
Oh.
Is it like down...
Is that it?
No.
No, it's not here.
Is it down here?
That's the mall.
This is...
Where you're making more babies again.
Okay, that's your third one.
It's not here.
The fuck is it?
Oh my god.
Where's the map?
I don't... Oh, there it is.
I found it.
Mario...
Gonna win!
Mwah!
Click.
The door opened.
Hmm.
Here we are.
Mwah ha ha!
It's done!
My hit new game that's gonna make me loads of money is complete!
Now to sell it!
Mario!
What are you doing here?
How'd you get into my studio?
Wait.
I just got one of my brilliant ideas.
Creatures of Diamond City is I, Wario!
Your most beloved and stinkiest gamer.
Today I have a special surprise for you all.
I'm releasing a new game for you all to buy!
Wario Mon!
It's so much better than that stinking Pydomon that you're all playing right now!
And to prove it, I have Mario here to wallow and defeat against my Wario Mon!
Mwah ha ha ha!
Something strange seems to be going on with Wario's PC.
Is that supposed to happen?
I downloaded this off the internet.
You wouldn't just download a game off the internet, right?
What?
Pokemon?
What is he doing in my video game?
Oh my god, Red?
Oh my god, the crossover.
You wouldn't just download Pokemon off the PC, would you?
The Nintendo lawyers are looking right now.
Ha ha ha ha!
Never fuck with the Nintendo lawyer!
Oh my god, it's not fair!
He had like...
...50-plus years of trading!
Quick, cover the screen!
The Nintendo ninjas.
Don't worry, I got a Vito throw.
Oh my god, it's red!
Oh my god, there's Lapras!
Don't worry.
Oh, I like how it's like the original sprite too.
That's so cute.
Don't worry, fire beats water, right?
If we put enough fire, if there's enough fire, it'll eventually beat water.
It'll overpower water.
Yes.
He's paralyzed, I'll take my 50.
No, I should heal him.
I was gonna say, I'll take my 50-50.
He could get paralyzed next.
Alright, let's get you some HP.
Yeah!
If there's enough fire, we can evaporate the water!
Exactly!
Okay.
Yeah, but I wanna...
I wanna, like, get enough...
I wanna make sure I heal before the next Mon comes in.
That's right, Dad.
You're so good.
He's like, please.
He's like, oh, I love Arcanine's original spray...
Or yellow spray.
That's so cute.
Until his last breath.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Dad.
I can fix you later.
Oh my god, it's a secular.
Oh, it's not very effective.
Well, I was gonna use that for the other one anyway.
Yay!
There's Husky Goon mooching off of Dad.
Uh...
With sharp fans...
Maybe low 80...
Stun...
Let's get rid of Vine Whip.
Actually...
Um...
I'm gonna grass move.
I'll get rid of Bite.
Sorry, you can't be a little kinky anymore.
Well, you can be ultra kinky with Crunch.
That's harder than...
But...
Crunch is a better Bite.
Alright, let's go...
Storm through.
Crunch is Bite, but cool.
That's what the C stands for.
C for cool.
Yay!
Level 29!
Wow, Charge.
What's that?
An electrical tackle that also hurts the users?
That's a gamble I'm willing to take.
It's just like when he jumped off the bed.
It's okay.
I'm trying.
It's okay, guys.
I'm...
I'm making a joke out of it.
Because, like...
I'm...
This is my way of coping.
That's...
Stop!
Wait!
Too soon!
Is that...
Yay!
I got 420!
Nice!
Wow!
I put 1 day's effort into this game and I lost.
I even cut corners on the mouth friends I used to make this.
What gives?
Mario booted up the PC, frankly, checking the game's files.
Pokemon?
What the heck is Pokemon?
This is just a cheap knockoff of Pokemon!
I can't believe it!
You got lucky, Mario!
Pokemon wishes it could be as good as Pokemon!
My game was supposed to defeat you, but I guess I just have to take care of you myself!
If you decide to come over here, what's with that nook?
I'm not gonna put that sort of effort in if I don't have to.
Are you ready?
Yeah, I am.
Wahaha!
Dad, you'll be okay.
You don't need heroes.
Oh, they gave me full HP!
It's Wario time!
Nice.
Dad was like, please, heal me.
I'm like, no, you're going straight in.
Oh my god.
You're already paralyzed?
Ow!
I have ramps!
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Level two.
Rantel?
Oh my...
Oh!
This is ramp!
Oh, I hated those.
It's from...
I forgot the game.
Super Mario World?
What was it called?
That was one of my favorite games as a child.
Yeah, the key guys!
Yes!
Mario 2?
Oh, wait, no!
Not Super...
The key guys!
Yeah, Mario 2!
It's one of my favorite...
It was so...
It was really hard.
I hated them.
The key guys, I hated...
I hated them so much.
It's okay.
You're already paralyzed so I can use that move.
Oh, wait.
I forgot I hurt itself.
Never mind.
I forgot that I hurt myself instead of paralyzing me.
Uh, nope.
Fuzzy B.
I'll just use Flame Wheel.
Flame Wheel!
Uh, Brady, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just got back from my sister's college graduation.
Whoa!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You had a great time.
Congratulations on your sister.
Graduating.
I remember playing, uh, Mario 2 for so long and I never completed it because it was so hard for me.
I was a stupid kid.
Um, headbutt, that's metal.
Might as well get out or tackle.
Poof!
Forgot tackle and learn headbutt.
No, you're still going in.
You're gonna...
Wait, what was Pyro...
Pyro...
Oh, it doesn't even matter.
Doesn't even matter.
You'll win anyway.
I'm gonna punch your bird!
Oh my god, I got so aggressive.
I just chomped down my cough drop instantly.
I said that and I chomped it down.
I was like, gonna punch you.
I like, chomped my cough drop in half.
Or don't die.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I was gonna be like, wait a minute.
I could have lost that.
There can only be one bird here.
I'll get rid of the competition.
What?
What can I win?
The Diamond City Power Star has fallen out of Wario's pocket.
And into Mario's hands.
Mario received the Diamond City Power Star.
I mean, uh...
Looks like the camera feed is breaking up.
Heh heh.
Now's my chance.
Request to Wire Inc.
is now complete.
Yeah!
I did it!
Okay, I need to...
go back to the Pokemon Center.
No, what?
Never mind.
Did I talk about this?
So, you know how they're like...
You'll never...
You won't download a car.
You know that famous quote?
A person...
Apparently, the person who made that ad...
illegally downloaded the font for that ad.
I thought that was so fucking funny.
You won't illegally download the...
People were like...
You wouldn't illegally download a font, would you?
Yeah, he stole the font...
To make...
He stole the font and the music...
to make the video ad.
Isn't that fucking crazy?
Really?
Yeah, I saw that, and then someone made a parody of it.
It's so ironic.
I guess I go to the next world.
I don't think there's anything else for me to explore.
I go home now.
Wait, where's home?
Was it Toad Town?
Yay!
We leave now.
Mario!
Sorry, that's my Luigi voice.
Wait, okay.
I can't do the Toad voice, so...
Uh, Pom, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Boy, am I glad to see you.
I'm just about finished up here.
You should be able to go to World 4 in just a moment.
Wait just a minute!
I'm Kamek.
Can't allow you to do that.
Lord Bowser attacked me with ensuring you don't repair this warp pipe.
And I won't let his furliness down.
The entire road toad.
Oh, wait.
Wait, did he send himself in?
Wait a minute.
But you were just there.
Wait.
You were just there.
Hold up.
This doesn't make sense.
Admin abuse.
How do you do a...
You're the full 23!
Wait a minute.
This is a bit not fair.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
None of this is a little fair, guys.
No.
Oh, no.
I have zero heals.
Oh, that's bad.
All right, guys.
I think dad might not survive.
Double crit hit?
What is this?
Dragoon?
Will we be okay?
Okay.
Body slam.
Guys, I don't have a full restore.
Oh, nice.
Dragoon, you got this.
Dude is for dead.
But Dragoon only lick.
How fight when Dragoon wants to lick?
Peace and love.
You not...
Oh, wait.
Lick?
Headbutt.
All right, guys.
I'm sorry.
You won't be allowed to swallow anymore.
It's time.
I'm sorry, Dragoon.
You won't be able to swallow.
What a relief.
Lord Bowser.
What's the point?
No, Donkey.
I'm going to get dumped now.
It's all I have.
No way.
Lord Bowser is going to kill me.
Don't think this is over, Mario.
I'll let you go this time.
As I'm going to think up an excuse to tell Lord Bowser so I don't get into trouble.
Oh, that was weird.
Let me just...
Let me just get this warp pipe all fixed up then.
There you go, Mario.
That warp pipe should be all fixed up.
Good luck out there.
All right.
Bye.
Toad.
I gotta fix that.
I love that.
I love that song.
I think you were waiting.
All right.
World 4.
And then we have...
Four more worlds after World 4.
See if we can get close to beating World 4 today.
Oh, it's...
Wait, what is this?
What world would this one be?
Do you know this entire area used to be a marsh?
I wonder what city this is going to be based off of.
I feel like I'm thinking about five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Oh my God, it's these guys.
Breaks.
Scuttlebug.
Have you heard about the scuttlebug?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You know, the scuttlebug.
Whoa, whoa.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
He's got special eyes.
Oh, no, not the flinch.
Cease now.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
No, tell me more.
Hey, wake up, wake up.
Have you heard about the scuttlebutt?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
One of my favorite songs.
Oh my God, kill it.
What the fuck is that?
What game?
Where are you from?
And why would they do this to you?
What?
Oh my God.
I can't.
It's raining.
I, if I could, I'd burn it with fire.
But it's raining.
Burn it in holy fire.
It looks like some fucking Dark Souls enemy right here.
I use electricity.
It's alright.
We'll do one more flame.
Bye-bye.
Oh, I keep forgetting to get Yuri into the party.
Wait, I got zero dollars?
Give me my money.
Here's your prize money.
But hey, wait a minute.
You don't have a coin case.
Here on Main Street, everyone uses purple coins.
Here, let me get you situated.
Wait, if I like randomly battle poor people, can I just like take their entire life?
Are they like legally required to pay me?
And here's your purple coins.
Like, if like, you know...
Like, don't just rob the homeless.
I'm just winning the laws in this, like, you know, Pokemon battle.
You know, but like, you know, poor...
Like, you know, someone who's poor might be like trying to do Pokemon battles to like make money.
You know, because they're like, you know, they're like, this is how I'm going to try to get income.
And they try to challenge me, not knowing that I have stronger Pokemons.
And so, like, if I win against them, are they like forced to pay me?
Like, what are the laws?
Like, am I...
Dude, are they like in debt to me?
Do they in debt to me?
Those are all anyone cares about around here.
Suspend them wisely.
Shoot.
Literally hustling.
I'm just wondering, like, how do you enforce the give money shit?
Like, how do they enforce it?
Hey, what gives?
I'm about to catch something big.
Oh my god!
I need this.
This is what I need in my exile box.
Oh, and it gives sweet kisses.
That's definitely what I need.
I'm setting up something special in my PC.
In my PC box right now.
We need it in the box.
We gotta make sure everyone's happy.
Bro, what is happening in that box?
Sorry.
To enter the box, you gotta sign an NDA.
If you wanna...
Those who enter the exile chamber must sign an NDA so nothing gets out.
Fish bones.
Oh, it's...
I don't need that guy.
Dad, please!
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna hurt myself, too.
Oops.
You can't...
Dad, please!
You can't faint yet!
I need you to hurt yourself a little bit.
I forgot about that.
When I sign an NDA, when you said me.
Name that mon after me.
That's when you...
It's like...
You know, I was like...
Remember to accept the terms and conditions?
That's my terms and conditions.
The moment an NDA was inserted in that terms of conditions.
And you didn't bother reading.
And you just scrolled all the way down and said yes.
You asked to be named...
To be named.
Boy, you fools.
You fools.
My contract is like a Disney contract.
You guys hear about that shit?
We're like...
If Disney accidentally kills you, they are legally freed from any death-related causes that Disney caused.
Because if you click yes on the terms and conditions of Disney+, and you die in Disneyland...
Disney is like legally freed from any like...
From...
From like being...
What's the word called?
Yeah, no.
Okay.
Like it's...
It actually happened in real life.
Like...
Yeah.
I don't know if they lost the case.
Or...
Oh yeah.
Like they're not liable.
They're not liable for anything that might have caused your death.
Like...
That was like...
That was their argument.
Like...
I don't know if they lost or won that.
I know they got a lot of lawyers to try and get out of it.
Oh, thank God they lost the case.
But that's wild.
My contract's like that.
But it...
But like we learned from the Disney case to like make it stronger.
Yeah.
So like basically what happened...
Was I was really sad.
Like...
Um...
A woman...
Like...
Had like an allergic reaction at Disneyland.
Um...
From eating like...
From eating something there.
And like she told him like...
Oh, does this have like...
I think it was like nuts or something.
Does this thing have nuts?
And the...
The guy was...
The restaurant owner was like...
No.
At Disneyland.
And she had an allergic reaction and passed away.
And then like...
This...
So then obviously the husband sued...
Disneyland...
Disney for that.
Because like...
That's fucking crazy.
Um...
That that happened.
And then...
Um...
Uh...
Disney was like...
Well...
She signed up for Disney Plus for a free trial.
And in our terms and conditions...
On Disney Plus...
We are not liable for whatever the fuck happens to you...
At any Disney location.
And that was their main argument.
They signed up for a free...
Trial.
Like...
But anyway...
That's my contract.
But we learned from the Disney case.
And we won't fail our trial.
So...
So you can't say nothing from...
You can't tell anyone...
What's going on in the Exile box.
I guess I got a way.
Take your purple coins...
And let me try again.
Okay.
I need to...
Figure out where...
If there's a place to heal.
Oh my.
You may seem like you need some rest.
I'm pretty sure they fixed Disney Plus...
Terms and conditions after that.
The moment you get into my ball...
My Mario ball...
You've said yes to my contract.
This entire area was only developed recently.
You know?
It used to be and still somewhat is on marsh because of this.
You can get some good fish in the nearby river.
Although you need this good rod in order to find them.
So here you go.
Don't be shy.
Yeah, no.
Fix it Disney.
100%.
They're gonna...
Of course it's gonna be fixed in Disney's favor.
They're gonna learn from the trial they lost...
To make it even more fucked up.
Yo, try it out.
Alright, fight me.
It's Disney.
Stopping around in these puddles sure is fun.
Oh my god, he's so happy.
Happy moon.
Oh my god,
he's so happy.
Happy moon.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This line, Evil Incorporated has the same number of syllables as Doofenshmirtz, Evil Incorporated.
Coincidence?
I think not.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's just a happy little guy.
Not all happy little guys are freaky, alright?
Sometimes they just... sometimes they might look freaky, but they're not.
They were just put in that way.
It's the ones you don't think look freaky that you gotta look out for.
The freakiest ones are the ones that look the most innocent.
Because they have something to hide.
They're like, inside, they're like, oh man, I'm too freaky.
I need to make sure no one knows.
They're always hiding something.
I don't trust them.
Always the ones you don't expect.
Huh?
Your prize?
Oh, here you go, mister.
I don't really care about purple coins or what these are anyway.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
It's like those... it's like the Perez.
The Shouplet!
Alright.
Time for you to lick it!
It's licking time!
Why is my egg not hatched yet?
Your baby takes so long to hatch!
Erpa!
Why is erpa?
Oh no, it poisoned me.
Oh, it poisoned you.
Alright.
Licking time!
That's not gonna stop me from licking it!
You're gonna lick that purple mushrooms!
No matter what!
Doki said lick it!
It's your food for today!
Alright.
Green continues to fly!
Time to catch it!
Alright.
Who wants to be the freaky mushroom?
In the exile chamber?
Yay!
Oh my god!
It's so weak!
A small baby purple Goomba!
Like alien!
It takes refuge near small villages.
It attacks by twirling which is often confused.
No!
Hahaha!
Who wants to go in the chain...
The exile room?
Dragoons!
Hahaha!
Things happen there!
Alright.
Co...
I just got...
Saw the first person that...
Uh...
That's uh...
Cosmic...
Goon...
Would that fit?
C...
G...
O...
It just fits.
Okay.
G...
O...
N...
Area.
I was gonna say...
Uh...
I see you spamming.
Maybe I...
No!
I'm joking.
I'm not that fucked up.
I...
It's like...
Wait.
You said me several times.
Let me remove that real quick.
Let me...
Hahahaha!
He was just really excited.
Alright.
Yay!
I'm much better now.
I'm okay now.
I took that lady's...
Um...
Oh wait.
What is that?
Jabba?
I took that lady's home remedy care.
She said don't...
She said...
I should...
I wouldn't need to go to the doctors.
They're fake news.
Just use those...
Old...
Old herbal remedies.
A fly with a nose.
It's like a little peanut.
Alright.
Lick it!
Hahahaha!
That's right!
Lick everything!
It's ours now.
Keep licking dragon!
Yeah!
Hahaha!
Keep licking it!
And I will watch!
Hahahaha!
Lucky please!
Hahaha!
Yay!
Jabba was caught!
We are all watching.
A tiny mosquito-like creature.
In its youth, it is prone to cowardice.
It takes lodge inside the trunks of great trees and is rumored to hide in bushes.
Alright, who wants to be a little Jabba?
That the Yoshi licked?
Alright, let's see.
Let's see.
I want to sign the NDA.
Oh, you think just because I read it, you're definitely gonna be picked?
No, no, no.
We got it.
Psyche!
Made you feel a little happiness today.
I...
Okay, here you go.
Um...
I...
I had to name that person.
Oh my god, it's him.
Oh my god, fuck this guy.
This guy is so ugly.
I don't know.
It's just...
It's so...
Oh, I know what it reminds me of.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, why do I keep bumping at him?
I don't want that.
What?
Get out!
The fact that it stares back at you two.
Oh, there's Spike!
We don't have Spike?
Oh, I think it's because I keep fighting spikes.
But I've never, like, actually captured one.
It's time to lick it.
Face your fears.
Yes!
Lick it, Dragoon!
Keep licking it!
We lick everything.
Wait, it doesn't affect him?
Oh, he doesn't like it.
He's like...
Oh, no!
What?
What do you mean you don't like it?
I don't understand!
Why don't you like it?
Oh, thank God he's normal.
All right.
Let's do... Okay, which one?
Ah!
I feel like if I use these, he's gonna...
He's gonna, like, die.
So I should just...
I'll just use the bite to slowly whittle it down.
Boo!
Normie!
All right, I guess you can rest your tongue for a little bit, Dragoon.
It's time to bite instead!
Just as freaky!
Yeah!
All right.
Pokeball time!
Lumber cat!
Chicken jocking!
Lava!
Ch-ch-ch-chicken!
If I ever gonna do another concert, I wanna sing that song.
That's my next Five Nights at...
That's my...
Next Five Nights at Freddy's song.
Chikori!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
A hard-working yet oblivious turtle.
It throws heavy spiked projectiles at perceived threats.
Its stomach is said to contain unlimited ammunition.
Oh yeah, for those who...
Oh yeah, that reminded me!
Um...
Uh...
For those who are wondering, um...
When we're uploading the songs.
Min and I actually, like, asked about it recently.
A week or two ago.
And they said, uh...
Like, some stuff happened.
They're like, oh, sorry for the poor communication and stuff.
But they'll get us the...
They'll try to get us the videos as soon...
Like...
Either this month or next month.
So I hope we can upload it soon.
I really wanna...
I really...
I mean, you guys have been waiting for a very long time for them.
Too.
So...
I hope we can upload the individual performances soon for you guys.
Alright, who wants to be Spike?
He's like a...
He's like a crowd favorite.
I've seen him around a lot.
Yeah, cause I know like some of you guys have been waiting for a long time.
For like the HD quality version of it.
Instead of like, you know, the camera rip.
Spike is a chill guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, he is.
Well, actually you need to use the bathroom.
I'll let you guys like fight each other before.
Alright.
I'll let you guys fight each other a little bit to be Spike before I pick one.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
You guys fight each other?
Alright.
Who won the fight?
Me!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
L, L, Soft, Rice, Mod!
Seij and Nexi, Allen, Mehdi.
Mike, forward, doc.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Pick me and my life is yours, Doki.
I'll show these other Mario moms who are the real bosses!
And Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would like to be Spike.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, but Meep won.
Oh, wait.
Were you guys voting?
All right.
Whichever one has the most...
Whichever super chat has the most votes becomes Spike.
It's... It's American Idol.
Wait, what is it?
American Idol, everyone.
Grab your phones and text us your winners.
And then that will be your next Dokimon.
Meep already won.
It's like, grab your phones and text your vote on this number right now.
Dragun against Dragun.
The game was rigged from the start.
All right.
I guess...
Meep is the only...
Call 1-800-DRAGOON.
Text your vote at 1-800-DRAGOON today.
Meep-goon.
There he is.
Wait, did Meep already have...
No, Meep didn't already have a mod, did he?
I don't think so, right?
Silent!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Did he...
Wait, don't get...
Don't get one, guys!
Gladstone just wants him...
Gladstone's trying to sabotage it.
Gladstone...
What if Gladstone actually...
Uh...
Actually knows...
It's...
Like...
Was lying...
And he's like, I'm gonna sabotage this.
Right?
Okay.
Meep...
Uh...
The long con...
Not Meep did have one.
All right.
We'll see here.
We'll see if Meep has one.
We can change it, right?
All right.
Exile time.
Don't let him deter us.
All right.
We'll see.
We're going back.
All right.
We'll see.
Demonic!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll never lose my...
My virginity because I never lose.
Meep probably.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's check...
Let's check the exile chamber and see if they're having fun.
All right.
Alex, Gus...
The Dragon, Hank, Cat, NextE, FOP, P, Tips, Smurf, Minion...
Oh, yeah.
This is...
I forgot.
We sold one.
Goodbye.
We traded one of them for this guy.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Oh, he was!
He was trying to sabotage it!
He's like, he's like spreading the word.
Meep, I should... Oh wait, I didn't want to... Sorry, Meep, you're going into the exile chamber.
I want to... I want to hear you, but like, I'm still trying to hash this fucking egg.
Saboteur!
I take the... I thank Steve for having this vote.
Thank you for the super chat, Meep.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey... How long does it take to hatch these?
Yeah, but I want to name the baby.
It will take some time.
It still doesn't tell me how... What?
It's so long!
I looked at the summary and it still says it might take some time.
I've been running around for so long.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I should buy more balls.
Oh, I only have like the regular ones.
I want like the stronger ones.
Oh, it's because I'm in the first town.
That's right.
I'll go buy in the next town then.
All right, let's go back to world four.
Yeah, but they don't have a Yoshi.
I don't have a Yoshi yet.
You have to like buy a Whistler or something.
I don't know if I caught all the mimes in this area, but let's see.
I still need to start fishing too.
I'll do like two more encounters here and see if we get there's any more.
We ever want to play Pokefusion?
What's Pokefusion?
Is that like one of the other ROM hacks?
Oh, I had a Whistle for free in the Toe Town?
Wait, really?
Which one?
The only reason why I don't...
The thing is, you don't see me play Pokemon games?
It's because I personally, I don't like one of the Toads.
But there's so many.
Oh, wait.
The thing is, I don't know if I talked to him before.
Sorry.
He's not that interesting.
Sorry, Toad.
I know you're...
Oh, my God.
Wow.
When does he stop?
There's a...
Oh, I got Red Candy!
Yay!
I was gonna say, I don't think I want to talk to him for a while.
Ah.
Oh.
The ocean is so nice this time of year.
Or my head would let me float in the water.
Who would have a Whistle?
I know I've talked to a lot of them already.
So I'm like, which one have I not talked to?
Yeah, I was gonna say, you seem like you talk a lot.
So I was like, I don't think I want to listen.
Got...
Which one?
Is it just the one free roaming?
Toad is just like Doki for real, for real.
The king of...
Yeah, for king.
Palm, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, which one is it?
I feel like I talked to all of them already.
Are they in the houses?
Or like, are they just roaming?
Oh!
Oh my god, he was outside.
You could have just said outside the building.
That...
Oh, don't worry.
Currently have a Yoshi.
In your party or not.
Like I said, it's magic.
Oh my god.
You could have just said it's outside.
Alright, where is...
Key items.
Register.
List.
Yay!
Oh, never mind.
Can't use that in there.
Why not?
He has rights.
Wee!
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not...
I'm not doing...
I'm not doing the wild encounters in this area anymore.
I think it's just spranglers now.
Alright, let's...
Let's go fishing!
I want to catch the one with the big lips.
Got the good rod.
Register.
Select.
Yay!
Give me the one with the big lips!
The fuck?
That's in...
64 too, right?
It's so familiar.
Get stick bugged.
Yeah, I got stick bugged.
Leave that fish.
It's time to lick it.
It's time to lick the bug.
Get scuttle bugged.
Alright.
Catch time!
Oh!
Oh wait, I thought I did like more damage.
But that was Dragoon's house for some reason.
Oh yeah, I was gonna say, the reason why I don't play Pokemon games on stream is that I personally don't like the formulaic of Pokemon games usually.
But because this is Mario, I, I, I figured I'd give it a shot just because it's like different and I figured they would like do experiment more with it.
Yay!
I caught the Skeeter!
Alright, who wants to be the Skeeter?
Who wants to be the stick bug?
A water-dwelling insect that is light enough to stand on the water surface.
Its aura is said to negatively affect the emotions of nearby trainers.
Alright.
It's stick bugged.
Alright, El.
You can be a stick bug!
I feel like you were gonna snap any moment.
Alright.
I need a catch.
I need a catch big lips.
God damn it.
It's another...
I got stick bugged again.
I got fucking stick bugged again.
God fucking damn it.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, sheep sheep.
I can't stick bug.
I need to catch big lips.
Come on, give me my big lips.
Oh, hey, this was good.
Oh, no, no, it's alright.
It's alright.
I want to get fishbone, too.
It's licking time.
Go in, dragon.
Lick for Dokio.
It doesn't help I'm wearing this mustache, too.
It really doesn't help that I'm wearing this mustache when I say that.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Let's see it.
Let me see it.
Okay.
I have an... No!
The licking was too strong!
You licked too hard!
Okay, wait, wait, guys.
I have an idea before... before I keep going.
I have an idea.
Let me disappear for a second.
I've got something important to do.
I...
This is very important, guys.
Where is it?
Where is it the thing I want to do?
Okay.
Where is it?
There's no way.
That actually already...
Don't worry, guys.
It's worth...
Oh, I do!
I do!
Ew.
Let me see... I forgot about that.
You guys must be so confused.
Like, what is she talking about?
What is she talking about right now?
Okay, wait.
That's right, Dragoon.
Look for Tokyo.
No!
Stop!
It's the reason I met.
That's enough for today.
Yay!
Don't worry.
We need to grab one.
Is it a big fish?
No!
This is a wild Tokyo.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, let me catch the... I need to catch the two fishes!
God damn it!
Stop stick bugging me!
I need... I need the fish!
Stop!
Wait, no one told me to fish... Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Is the fishbone one a rare encounter?
I didn't realize.
I forgot ghost type is weak against ghost type.
Or dark... Oh wait, he's licking his dark side.
Ghost type is weak against dark.
No!
I brought my camera and everything!
I mean, he caught the big fish here.
Stop stick bugging!
Oh, is it ghost?
No, lick is ghost.
Yeah, I didn't... Oh yeah, I didn't realize ghost type was weak.
I forgot.
I forgot ghost type is weak against ghost.
Oh my
god, it's just stick bug!
It's the...
It's...
It's still stick bug!
Oh my god.
Come on!
Oh my god, it's out of here.
I didn't realize fishbone was a rare encounter.
I'm always getting stick bugged or cheep cheep.
I can't believe it.
Okay, I'm gonna do two more.
I'm gonna do two more, guys.
Two more.
I'm gonna do two more.
There has to be another one.
No!
I brought the camera for nothing!
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's just stick bug!
The game gets stick bugged.
There has to be...
There has to be another...
Oh my god!
Okay, one... two more, two more.
I'll do two more.
I can't stick bugged.
Again.
The game...
Yes!
Okay, I now know.
I know now.
Oh, but I don't have any weak ma...
Okay, maybe vine whip?
Maybe vine whip will be good.
I know like...
Oh, but you're level 20.
I'll try vine whip.
Maybe grass type.
It's water ghost!
Oh no!
I'll stun it then.
I'm gonna stun it.
I forgot.
I just saw dead fish and then I was like, it's dead!
Grass can't hurt you no more!
Oh wait, why did I bring it?
Oh wait.
Why did I bring the camera?
I'm doing normal things.
Alright.
Don't worry dra...
Don't worry dragoons.
Filming...
Dragoons first battle!
It's like I'm at a baseball game, right?
This is like...
Guys, I'm...
I'm like...
It's like...
You know...
I'm being very wholesome.
It's dragoons first battle!
Wow!
Look at him growing up.
Yeah, like a good father.
Look at that.
I'm so wholesome.
This is why I have a camera on.
Wow!
Look at you go, son!
Look at you go!
Wow!
Good job!
No!
Run!
Run for the home run!
Yay!
Okay, you go!
You go, son!
That's my dragoon!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Nice.
A fish skeleton.
It hungers for the blood and flesh it once had.
Setting its sights on the first living thing in its future.
Best in the bisque.
Okay!
Who wants to be the dead fish?
It's ghost and aquatic and it's basically me.
Pretty please.
Thank you for the super chat, orca!
Thank you, thank you.
Are you also dead inside?
Good for you!
I mean...
Orca...
Gooon!
Oh.
Nice!
Yeah!
Alright, I'm gonna call it here, because we have Good Night Dragons soon.
Uh, but it was fun!
I streamed longer than two hours, but I was actually- I was having a lot of fun.
If my throat wasn't dying, we didn't have another stream tonight, um, I would keep going.
But, I've been having a lot of fun with this series, and I hope you guys have been too.
Guys, uh, I'm gonna raid my stream into Good Night Dragons, and I'm gonna push the stream maybe like 15 minutes back.
Just so I can have a little longer rest.
But, thank you everybody for watching today!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun!
Um, it's always fun hanging out with you guys, and I'm glad to have, like, more, like, you know, audience participation in this one.
Um, and I know it's really hard to get named, but I'm trying my best to, like, balance out the namings and stuff for the dragons.
Uh, but I hope you guys are enjoying, uh, you know, participating and being more involved in this game, compared to the other games I play.
Anyway, guys!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, watch your check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you slept for me, head to bed!
Cause, you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!